[Música]
en los escombros del titán encontraron
presuntos restos humanos esas fueron las
palabras literales que utilizó la
guardia costera luego de que el buque
canadiense artic recuperar algunos de
los fragmentos del sumergible que
implosionó durante su expedición al
Titanic
el fuego de los incendios forestales de
Canadá vuelve a extenderse hacia Estados
Unidos ciudades del noreste del país
están viendo empeorar la calidad de su
aire Chicago fue el miércoles por
segundo día consecutivo la ciudad con el
peor aire del mundo
chile asumió la presidencia pro tempore
de la alianza del Pacífico lo hizo luego
que México se negara a entregarle el
mandato a Perú tras la detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo será chile
quien finalmente se la entregue el
próximo agosto
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano mi
nombre Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos este
Informativo en Canadá donde sacaron del
fondo del mar algunos de los fragmentos
del sumergible titán que implosionó con
cinco personas adentro durante su
expedición a los restos del Titanic la
junta de investigación Marina que
conformó la guardia costera
estadounidense para investigar el caso
analizará los escombros e intentará
saber más de la causa de la catástrofe
además la guardia costera afirmó que
encontró restos que se presumen son de
humanos
Los profesionales médicos de Estados
Unidos llevarán a cabo un análisis
formal de los presuntos restos humanos
que se han recuperado cuidadosamente
entre los escombros en el lugar del
incidente y los cerca de 490 incendios
forestales que siguen Ardiendo en Canadá
están afectando el aire de Estados
Unidos especialmente en las ciudades que
limitan al noreste con el territorio
canadiense y que están sobre los grandes
lagos por segundo día consecutivo
Chicago ha sido la ciudad del mundo con
la peor calidad del aire
Chicago amaneció con la peor calidad del
aire de todo el mundo y con un Horizonte
parcialmente oscurecido por el humo de
los incendios forestales en Canadá estos
días varias ciudades norteamericanas han
sido afectadas como Nueva York bitsberg
y Detroit causando contaminación y
preocupación entre los residentes en
total más de 100 millones de
estadounidenses estaban lidiando con la
mala calidad del aire en la tarde del
miércoles
hoy he visto a alguien corriendo y le he
dicho Oye de más despacio ponte una
mascarilla no te esfuerces demasiado
Cuanto más respiras y Cuanto más fuerte
respiras estás inhalando literalmente un
fuego humo de campamento en tus pulmones
Así que
este humo viajó desde Canadá donde los
incendios arrasan desde hace varias
semanas de este bosque por ejemplo solo
quedan árboles carbonizados tierra negra
y un humo espeso ya se han quemado más
de siete millones de hectáreas en el
país y los incendios han liberado
representa miga toneladas de emisiones
de carbono un récord eso es más del 10%
del total de las emisiones mundiales del
año pasado
en términos de consecuencias climáticas
también hayosina y carbono negro que con
el flujo atmosférico adecuado puede
acabar en el Ártico puede asentarse en
el hielo o en la capa de hielo de
Groenlandia lo que potencialmente puede
acelerar el deshielo y contribuir al
calentamiento global
los científicos están preocupados ya que
las emisiones continúan a escala masiva
en todo el país en Canadá más de 250
incendios permanecen fuera de control
a partir de este miércoles chile asumió
la presidencia pro tempore de la alianza
del Pacífico Esa fue la solución que
pactaron los cuatro países miembros
luego de que México se negara a ceder el
mandato a Perú limas ejercerá la
presidencia transitoria a partir de
agosto
una solución diplomática a un conflicto
político de meses chile ejercerá la
presidencia pro tempore de la alianza
del Pacífico uno de los mayores
organismos de integración diplomática y
comercial de América Latina lo hará
luego de que México se opusiera a ceder
el mandato a Perú siempre hemos
reconocido el derecho que le corresponde
al Perú para ejercer la presidencia Pro
tempore creo los cuatro países seguimos
Igualmente comprometidos con el futuro
de la alianza la cancillería peruana
confirmó rápidamente la noticia y
agradeció a Santiago su rol diplomático
para que la alianza compuesta también
por Colombia chile y México pueda
continuar en funcionamiento
el acuerdo alcanzado refleja la voluntad
política de seguir apostando por la
integración latinoamericana que favorece
el diálogo el intercambio económico
comercial la cooperación y la inserción
internacional durante semanas el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador se ha negado a ceder la
presidencia temporal a su homóloga
peruana a pesar de que era Lima aquí en
la correspondía recibirla López Obrador
atilado de Usurpadora a la presidenta
Dina boluarte quien sucedió al
expresidente Pedro Castillo en medio de
la crisis política en el país andino
cuando Castillo ordenó la disolución del
Congreso de su país no le puedo yo
entregar nada porque este
ella
no Es legal y legítimamente para
nosotros presidenta del Perú
el congreso peruano declaró personas no
ingrata a López Obrador y hasta el
momento no hay señales de que le levante
este señalamiento tras el acuerdo
alcanzado con los otros miembros de la
alianza Perú finalmente asumirá la
presidencia pro tempore del órgano el
próximo 1 de agosto
agresivo cada 28 de junio se conmemora
el día del orgullo
lgbtiq más el año pasado 131 personas
trans fueron asesinadas en Brasil son
datos de la asociación Nacional de
travestis y transexuales para superar el
estigma asociado a este colectivo y
fomentar su empleabilidad un grupo de
profesores de la universidad Federal de
Río de Janeiro ha creado un programa de
formación profesional exclusivo para
trans enfocado al sector de la
hostelería
pasado marcado por el juicio pero
también tiene un futuro luminoso por
delante esta mujer trans y negra acaba
de firmar un contrato con uno de los
mejores hoteles de Copacabana para crear
su carta de cócteles
son cosas que nunca imaginé para mí
porque mi vida era un gueto y un
submundo tener un hotel como este que me
ofrece la oportunidad de mostrar que soy
capaz de presentar mi trabajo a personas
diversas me engrandece de una forma tal
que solo pienso que quiero más mucho más
Desde hace 14 años Brasil mantiene el
récord de ser el país con el mayor
número de homicidios de personas trans
del mundo
iniciativas como esta contribuyen a
aumentar la integración de este
colectivo en Brasil sólo el 14% de los
trans y travestis consiguen un empleo
formal el 90% tuvo que recurrir a la
prostitución como única forma de
subsistencia en algún momento de su vida
tenemos muchas iniciativas y muchas
actividades notamos mucha más aceptación
que rechazo nuestra política de
inclusión dura todo el año y no solo en
el mes del orgullo lgbti
el caso de josely resume el esfuerzo de
este colectivo para eliminar barreras
ella se formó en la universidad Federal
de Río de Janeiro donde existe un
programa pionero para formar una nueva
generación de profesionales trans para
el sector de la hostelería
desde 2019 50 alumnos han pasado por
trans garzón 20 han encontrado trabajo
en este campo trans garzón es el único
curso de Brasil especializado en la
formación de personas trans mantenemos
un banco de currículum destinados a
empresas que colaboran con nosotros y
que tienen interés en trabajar con la
inclusión y la diversidad históricamente
la discriminación expulsa los trans de
las escuelas este proyecto intenta
garantizar el acceso y la permanencia de
estas personas en el mundo del trabajo
las personas trans tienen además una
esperanza de vida media que en países
como México no supera los 37 años
anteriormente hablamos con Andrés forero
Ordóñez gerente de campañas del
movimiento all out en América Latina que
nos explicaba que ha tenido y tiene de
particular la lucha por los derechos
trans en la región
las personas con esperanza de vida atrás
son sujeto de mayor índices de violencia
México es el segundo país a nivel
regional y global con mayor número de
feminicidios eso es feminicidios a
mujeres transportados 100% por el odio
entonces sigue siendo una lucha muy
presente en Brasil también seguimos
viendo episodios de violencia contra las
personas trans altos en Colombia y en
muchos otros países de América Latina
casos muy conocidos Como el caso de
Vicky Hernández en Honduras que pues
justamente también nos dejan ver que el
estado no se ha encargado bueno que los
estados que los gobiernos
latinoamericanos no sean encargado 100%
de cuidar y proteger los derechos de las
personas con experiencia de atrás
entonces Esta es una lucha que continúa
y es una lucha que es bastante
importante visibilizar justamente porque
lo que te decía al principio O sea la
testa dentro de la lgbt no pero la lucha
por las por los derechos de las personas
trans pienso que es de las luchas más
importantes actualmente
en Colombia por ejemplo se está
liberando el tema de la ley integral
trans una ley que busca proteger a las
personas trans de manera global aquí en
México también se están adelantando
estas batallas entonces
justamente pues justamente es eso no
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a grandes 24
[Música]